let's move on to the next award which is
the best story uh now I mean there's
lots of great stories obviously from us
from guests yeah but they can only be
one so let's look at the nominations
we've got uh Connor fortnite dancing at
God's wedding which is definitely the
weirdest thing I've seen in mind that is
a fever dream uh Pete's voice acting
experience at a Japanese cult I love
this story it just doesn't sound real
yeah
uh and then obviously Nigel's uh entire
origin it's just this entire there
wasn't one that we could pin down here
yeah it's just too much there's too much
there was too much uh gant's Bird Story
I think this is the one in Thailand yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you just watching
like a photo Coming of Age anime with
two birds Who Loved this next one uh
I was like what is that oh it's when Joe
is like a thousand dollars getting your
Mario Brother's ringtone
that's uh that was not my proudest
moment
he's like what the [__] is this
oh my ass beat that day
and then we go dinos losing his rent
money because I flew out of his shoes
yeah this this one is probably like the
closest one because normally uh for the
last I guess like two years of the best
story was we've always had like a big
between like like one of the three of us
having a big like oh yeah Revelation
about our backstory that no one knew
about and we've never mentioned to each
other epic story like the [__] video
games
the Guard law you know if you're
following that but this year it's been
it's three years you know a lot about us
already so it's just some wild [__] that
happened in other people's lives yeah
honestly yes but they can only be one
winner yeah I don't know what I actually
don't know what's going to win this one
I have no idea either but the winner of
the best story is
Pete's voice acting experience at a
Japanese call
well there's no dance
that was an amazing story yeah so funny
and so engaging yeah such a good
Storyteller Amazing Story it definitely
deserves the best story award absolutely
for this year what were the uh what were
the top three though three was Pete's
voice acting experience
holy [__] dancing
all right good stories good stories all
around well that that's that category
the next one do you know what's Wild
Pete didn't even get for like half of
the stories in his life no no I need two
more episodes yes to cover some ground
holy [__] uh the next award is and one
close to my heart the biggest clown now
of course I've been a champion of this
two times in a row yes so hoping finally
that I don't win at this time because I
don't want this award anymore so the
nominations are as follows Joey what do
they speak Connor Aer Lingus gaunt and
Chris so I know which one I want to win
oh yes I know which one I want to win I
think the real question is who comes
second all right because because I think
we can all know who's won this one yeah
do we really know I really hope you guys
pause well there there was one you know
one standout clown this year really went
above and beyond it yeah it was and and
the funny thing is all of this was like
off camera as well but it off camera
became an entire story arc that people
got invested in yeah you know it had its
ups and downs me bullying Air Lingus on
Twitter yeah Reddit was having a field
day with this yeah we get one of the
bags back and it turns out it wasn't the
bag the less expensive equipment and
just as soon as we had lost hope he had
been like nine months you get the email
we get the email and it's like we have
your bag
and we didn't believe it we didn't
believe it I didn't believe it until I
had the physical bag in my hand before I
know it was like someone else's back you
know it was it was empty right it wasn't
empty yeah someone had stolen all our
equipment we didn't know but uh it was
an entire story arc that had a good
ending yeah we didn't think it did
doesn't make a Lingus and you're less of
a clown though who do you think's gonna
come second hopefully not me I mean one
of uh one of us in this is wearing the
clown costume so I'm
yeah I I I don't know I feel like uh the
Game of Thrones take
bad that produced uh the Game of Thrones
take the light mode take that produce so
much heat on the Reddit that um I think
I might have swayed a few people I know
it's not gonna be me that's for sure all
right all right well let's find out who
the winner is the winner of biggest
clown of 20 no that's not eight years
just yeah it is congratulations
quite as above and beyond in the act of
being a clown as Air Lingus every single
opportunity they fumbled every single
aspect of communication was terrible yes
and every chance they had to redeem
themselves they missed so they are
indeed the biggest clown of this year
how much did they win by though
55.3
yeah so the question is who is second
place
was one company making a Monumental [__]
up for nine months in order to take the
biggest clouds I still had some decent
amount of votes
a quarter of them still voted for you
all right gone what's the next category
all right but the next one the opposite
of Clan rate is of course biggest shot I
mean we've had a lot of hard Chads on
the show a lot of Chad moments a lot of
Chads in the show to like I guess bring
that up as well because we had a lot of
guests this year as well so there were a
lot more nominations this year for
biggest Chad which is why this year's
nominations were Chris oh yeah with the
with the winning the chess boxing it was
pretty Peter
uh we got Joey I look disgusted
we got Hassan who's the only real
picture yeah we got Felix
the Chad burning down the building and
we got shinderell all right not not bad
a very stacked line everybody very very
stats lineup this year for I mean if
we're going by the definition of the
word right okay it's probably not going
to be any of us no right it's probably
going to be like a tie between like
maybe Felix Hassan maybe even Chris for
winning the chess boxing I think narrow
could take it I take it he could take it
as well take it shout of Storytelling
yeah sure who knows honestly this is one
of those categories where I I don't
expect anything and I won't be shocked
by anything this is one of us all right
yeah so let's see who wins this is I
have no idea who's going to win this
yeah actually let's find out though so
you guys have voted the biggest chart in
the trash taste Awards is
[Music]
[Applause]
all right next one is a brand new one as
well we have the biggest W of the year
uh now this is trash taste uh there's
not a lot to choose from but uh let's
have many of those but uh let's let's
see which ones we had this year we had
Conor winning the horse race and the
road trip special I mean
small W yeah sure uh God getting married
that's a big W uh Connor cyclathon also
a Big W AER linger's bag returned I mean
that's like a is that a double here it's
it's a w considering the entire well
everything that's W on our wallets yeah
yeah it's a w on our wallets and then
Chris winning the chess boxing also a w
yeah I mean there were quite a few W's
this year
um I love I realizing none of these
actually have anything to do with actual
episodes
rather than the special everything is
outside of the scope
I feel like I feel like part of this was
a lot of big things happened off camera
for us as well although I don't think
Chris should win anything for wearing
this Dr jelly shorts those things yeah I
don't excuse you that's my face why do
you look so [__] awful in those
pictures yeah because it's like crispy
it's like crispy I'm gonna say this I'm
real happy that Chris won the chess
boxing but
um him throwing his Queen I still yeah
that was a big ass uh he he went from
like a guaranteed Checkmate to throwing
his Queen I believe and I I remember
screaming at my television uh when that
was like I couldn't I could not believe
I could not believe that honestly I kind
of want to give it to Connor I kind of
like Connor did Connor Connor did
something impressive this year all I did
was say I do now that that was it that
was it that's a w that everyone hopes
and all you can eat free oven baked
pizza that's and you paid for it
and all you can drink espresso Martini
it is an open bar
we've made God's Wallet work for that
bar poor God all right well out of all
of the W's which one was the biggest one
let's find out the winner of the biggest
W of the year is
God getting married
[Applause]
I did say I did say I do and uh I will
always be known as a grant for the rest
of my life now because I I can't believe
that happened on uh on the most
important moment of my life it should be
wedding times three yeah
three though
thank you thank you very much very much
followed by on the Cycles
very very well deserved third place
third place was Chris wins
wow okay so most of those were those
three yeah yeah I mean big W's all
around with the little W's we have on
trash days we'll take all of them yeah
that's good thank you very much